The Joe Rogan experience.
Norm MacDonald at one point was a handsome guy,
but he lived on a farm with his grandpa in the middle of nowhere.
So I don't think he got the handsome love.
Yeah, he's a great guy. He's my hero. I love him to death.
Well, maybe one of the funniest guys on the planet, David tell norm,
and that this, something.
About those two national treasures. I agree.
And, and the fact that he's not like the biggest comic of all time is weird.
Well, here's to us, I guess.
The comics, I mean, he's not the biggest,
but the comics he's on the Mount Rushmore keeps getting bigger.
Foreheads is not a good enough not to stop using that thing. Yeah.
It's a bad thing to say the Mount Rushmore, but uh, in the hall of fame,
hall of fame, there you go. Yeah. He's in the hall of fame.
You got another level where he's invented certain things. I never knew,
like he's, he's taken common to this higher point, which I didn't know existed.
Like I wish.
Well example another guy too, that still does real comedy. Like he,
when he goes on stage, he's still, he's ballsy. Yeah. He's swings. Right?
Like, Hey, and he gets confused if everybody's mad, like what's happening. Yeah.
Just a joke here. Folks.
Was, he's a, I don't want, you don't have to pull this up. Cause it's long.
But there was a radio show, like a morning show,
like you have to do on the road for press and he's doing one. And he's like,
well, you know, black people, they're poor. And the lady is like, Oh my God,
how can you say that norm? That is so racist. Like, I'm not,
I'm reading the newspaper. I'm watching the news. I'm looking at the stats.
They're poor. And she's like, Oh my God. And all these black women calling,
they go Norm's right. We're poor. It sucks. And he's like, you see, you see,
it was such a great moment. What radio show was that? It's on YouTube.
I don't know. It was just some Dick. Listen, TJ's in the morning, you know?
Oh,
one of things don't like him doing things when he was doing his Netflix show.
one specifically did not want him doing interviews because he got on the Howard
stern show. And he wanted to say, well,
if you think that way you're retarded, but he didn't,
he didn't want to be offensive. So,
well you think that you must have down syndrome.
He thought that'd be the better thing to say. I guess everybody is.
I'm not sure everybody started freaking out like that. He said that. Right.
Instead he thought he was like covered his tracks.
Right.
So he couldn't do interviews after that. Yeah.
He's brilliant. I mean the little things like the,
he's just one of those guys who describes the most basic that we all know.
But it's funny when he, cause he points it out.
Like his Letterman set the last Letterman when he goes, uh, yeah.
Germany decided to attack the world in hell and you're like, that's so true.
And then he goes, who do you think you are? Mars? I mean, it's just so funny.
Those little things where he's just telling you facts and it's funny.
Yeah. Well, he's a, he's a unique dude. You know,
there's a lot of unique people in this, uh, weird art form. Have.
You hung out with him? Yeah. I've hung out with him. I.
Hung out with him twice. Accidentally on two separate occasions,
the air planes I told you about it. I heard.
They are the one of them and was, yeah.
That's hilarious. Soon as he landed,
he was talking about how great it was to quit smoking. As soon as he landed,
he ran into the gift shop and bought cigarettes.
It was lighting them before he was on his way out the door. I go,
I thought you quit. He goes, I did talking about it. I want her to smoke. Yeah.
He just does what he wants to feel. On two occasions,
I was sitting next to him on a plane catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan
experience for free. Only on Spotify.
Watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs. All for free.
Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.